if i could just uh make a couple of
comments about uh
joe rogan
so
i've there's a bunch of people in my
life
who have inspired me who have taught me
a lot
who um i even look up to
the
many of them are alive most of them are
dead
i i want to say that uh so joe said a
few critical words about the
conversation with francis collins most
of it offline with a lot of great
conversations about it
some he said publicly
and
he was also critical to say that
me asking
hard questions in an interview is not my
strong suit
and i really want to kind of respond to
that
which i did privately as well but
publicly to say that
joe's 100 right on that
but that doesn't mean that always has to
be the case
and that is definitely something i want
to work on because most of the
conversations i have i want to see the
the beautiful ideas in people's minds
but there's some times where you have to
ask the hard questions to bring out the
beautiful ideas
and um it's hard to do
it's a skill and and joe is very good at
this
he says the way he put it in in his uh
criticisms
and he does this in his conversations
which is whoa whoa
there's a kind of sense like did you
just say what you said
let's let's make sure
we get to the bottom we clarify what you
mean
because sometimes
really
big
negative or difficult ideas can be said
as a as a quick aside in a sentence like
it's nothing
but it could be everything and you want
to make sure you catch that and you you
talk about it and not to not as a gotcha
not as a
kind of way to destroy another human
being but to reveal something profound
and that's definitely something i want
to work on i also want to say
that uh
as you said you disagree with joe on
quite a lot of things so for a long time
joe was somebody that i was just a fan
of listened to he's now
a good friend
and i would say we disagree more than we
agree
and i love doing that
and uh but at the same time
i learned from that so
it's like duel like
nobody in this world can tell me what to
think
but i think
everybody has a lesson to teach me
i think that's a good way to approach it
like i whenever somebody has words of
criticism
i
assume they're right and walk around
with that idea
to really sort of empathize with that
idea because there's a lesson there and
oftentimes
uh my understanding
of
of a topic becomes uh
is altered
completely or it becomes much more
nuanced and much more
much richer for the that kind of
empathetic process but definitely
i do not allow anybody to tell me what
to think whether it's joe rogan
or fiero dostoevsky or nietzsche or my
parents or um the
the like
the proverbial girlfriend which i don't
actually have
like all the
but she's still busting my balls exactly
exactly in my imagination i have a
girlfriend in canada
you